john gray's 28 years of age he's in his
fifth year at the big league level six
for 225 pounder lifetime against the
giants
he is
one in five with a 5.30 era here in
coorsfield 0-2 with an 8-2-0 era so the
giants have always now alex dickerson
high drive to right
dickerson
it is out of here and it's in the upper
deck
an amazing home run by alex dickerson
planting one in the upper deck at coors
field which is not often done
and the giants have a one-nothing lead
and the best part about dickerson is he
cannot hide how good that feels all
smiles coming back to the giants dugout
two-seat fastball down and in see it
later
so not two down it will take a hit
or a rocky's mistake to get another run
home donovan solano the hitter
lines this one into center field hampton
on the move still it's polar it's over
his head
longoria is going to score what's belt
going to do
well he's going to score
in solano you're right
he makes him pay and it's three nothing
the hill tonight for the giants will be
kevin gausman big right-hander 6-2 190
pounder
he is 29 years old and his seventh year
at the big league level so looking for
his first win against the rockies so
here's tapia
got him and that's how the bottom of the
first gets started and here is the
powerful nolan aronado 20 batted in at
268 average not bad numbers
now he swings ground ball to short
crawford's got it the throw to first
in plenty of time
so a shot down inning for gausman here's
joey bart 5 for 31 in his big league
career with 15 strikeouts
shoots this one up the middle for a base
hit
he got a fastball in and he sent it
right back up the middle
no over shift
straight up for dickerson
dickerson hits another high drive to
right
it is out of here
second home run of the game for
dickerson
and his third home run in the last two
games
five to nothing giants that way he was
off balance that was just
hands and wrists in that swing he was
kind of hunched over reaching down for
that low end and boom
brandon belt he's got a lead off to
bagger
line drive base hit center field
so crawford comes through with the two
out rbi single and it's six to nothing
given the high knuckles here's joey bard
who singled and scored in the second
hit on the ground and off the glove of
hampton as crawford was taking off on
the pitch and he's gonna score at seven
nothing got to get something going we've
been saying that quite a bit they're
down seven nothing here's the two two
that ball's well hit to left that's
gonna get on out of here now the rockies
have a home run okay
garrett hampson's third of the year the
spinning slider that stayed flat
here didn't miss it well the rockies
hadn't scored in 14 innings forget hold
on scored period
and then he bounced off to short
shoots this one up the middle and a base
hit
and the throw home and dickerson's going
to make it
so longoria comes through with a base
hit and it's eight to one murphy to fly
ball to center field
hit well to right
yastrinsky over he dives and he makes
the catch
he was in the air for a while and he
takes it away from murphy well he had to
come a long way for because they had
him shaded over towards
oh i'd say he's about eight steps out of
straight away center or right field
towards center but he comes from out of
nowhere and you know what this does to
gausman
that's just like getting your gas tank
filled up absolutely that puts that kind
of effort on get you out duvan is over
two he's hit two fly balls one to left
one to right
duvan slashes it in the left field of
base hit nice two strike two out at bat
yastrimsky over two with a walk
and he drives one into right center
field pilar on the move pilar looking up
it's off the very top of the wall
and coming in to score easily is dubon
and it's a triple for ustrinsky
so hampstead will come up played in all
35 games couple times as the dh
this ball is going to be number two of
the night garrett hamster this even
farther
about five rows short ended up on the
concourse
[Music]
well it's uh
the giants nine garrett hampson two
here's the two and two pitch
swing and that ball is uh a drive in the
right center field that gets down for a
base hit the belt is coming around third
he's gonna be waved home here goes to
throw to third and safe at third is
flores
on a one hop throw
belt scores and it is ten to two giants
here's crawford crawford one for three
and crawford hits a high drive to right
it is out of here
and crawford hits his fourth of the year
and the giants have busted this one wide
open he was leaning on that
one dickerson goes the other way hit
well
it is
out of here
he's got a three-homer game
he's got three more
rbis and it's now 16-2
have a night wow
the post-game interview
he said that's the best i felt about my
swing i haven't got a whole lot of
production out of it yet but i'm
swinging good two seamer out over the
plate
stays down through it on the outside
corner back spins it right over the wall
in left field
and the dickerson smile he can't can't
possibly be cool he has to smile
here's hoffman to the plate
swing and a hanging curve ball is ripped
down the left field line that is just
fair it will roll into the corner
dickerson scores robertson right behind
him and stopping at third will be rough
a two-run double for donovan solano and
the giants have hit 20.
drew butera
dickerson drives one to the left hit
pretty well
and it's off the bottom of the wall and
he almost knocked one out of the park
unbelievable